Every day, humans make dozens of judgements,
from deciding whether our clothes match to
determining whether a shady character
in the street is a threat.
Such decisions aren’t based on hard-and-fast rules,
a new study reveals.
Instead, our concept of “threat” -
and even of the color “blue” – is all relative.
To make the find, researchers showed non color-blind
participants a series of 1000 dots ranging
from very blue to very purple, and asked them
to judge whether each dot was blue.
For the first 200 trials,
participants saw an equal number of dots
from the blue and purple parts of the spectrum,
but then the prevalence of blue dots gradually
decreased to just a fraction of what it was before.
By the end of the study,
participants’ interpretation of the colors had changed:
dots that they had thought were purple
in the first set of trials they now classified as blue
That is, their concept of the color blue
had expanded to also include shades of purple.
Even when the researchers forewarned participants
that blue dots would become rarer and promised
them money if they kept their judgments consistent,
the same shift occurred.
And the team found similar results in
more complex versions of the task, where participants
had to judge whether a face was threatening
or if a research proposal was ethical.
When threatening faces became less common,
people started to consider previously benign
examples as posing a threat.
These results could explain why so many people
tend to be pessimistic about the state of the world.
As common problems become rare, previously
minor issues start to seem much more problematic.